hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll the thing about complex systems
which is a frequent focus of our
attention here is that by definition
they are complicated they can be very
different from each other you can be
complicated in different ways you know
simple things are kind of alike but
complicated things are all complicated
in their own particular way the Galaxy
is a complex system our brains are
complex systems the US economy is a
complex system the Ecology of the Amazon
rainforest is a complex system but all
of these systems are obviously wildly
different from each other so how do you
even say that there is a field called
complex systems but the nice thing is by
thinking about it hard and by looking at
data especially people have come to
realize that complex systems very often
maybe not always this is the nature of
the beast in this kind of science but
very often share certain features they
have hierarchical structure that could
be characterized as a network kind of
structure scale free networks in
particular are a kind of network
structure that shows up over and over
again so I'm very interested in this
stuff and one of our former mindscape
guests Henry Farrell my new colleague
now that I'm at Johns Hopkins Henry is
at the SNF Agora Institute here at
Hopkins he pointed me to a paper by a
sociologist Brooke Harrington and her
collaborators that it's about a new well
discovering that A system that had been
studied quite a bit can be thought of as
a complex system and a scale-free
network and the system we're talking
about is offshore wealth managers so
these are the people who will if you're
a billionaire in that uh realm of of
financial happiness you need people to
manage your money and some people want
to in particular save themselves from
being taxed or being sued food right or
you know going to jail and having their
wealth confiscated being subject to
sanctions if you're a Russian oligarch
or something like that so there's a
whole ecosystem of wealth managers that
store people's wealth in offshore
accounts and hide it from other people
who are trying to get it okay and Brooke
Harrington actually is a sociologist who
has studied these people and she has a
wonderful story of how do you study
wealth managers because they're
notoriously secretive they're not there
to spill their guts to nosy sociologists
so she actually got the training she
took a two-year course in becoming a
wealth manager and talked to everyone
who was her fellow student as well as
people who were managers at the time and
on the basis of that wrote a book
Capital Without Borders wealth
management and the one percent and more
recently she became aware of the fact
that it could be helpful to think of
this system as a complex system there's
enormous number of questions here
politically economically morally uh and
just you know personal financially right
but she wanted to think about the
network structure and how that could
help us understand and perhaps deal with
this complex system especially because
you know there's absolutely benign
reasons to have wealth managers you know
managing your retirement or doing your
taxes or whatever but there's also less
benign reasons hiding from the rules
that you're supposed to be obeying so
sometimes if you want to enforce those
rules understanding the structure of
this kind of network is very important
and not only is it a sort of scale-free
network but it's a different kind of
scale-free network depending on what
kind of oligarchs we're talking about
the US the uh the UK Hong Kong Russia
China all have slightly different
perspectives on how this works so I
thought this is a fun podcast to do
because it's sociology right it's human
behavior on Moss in a group context but
looked at through the lens of complex
systems research with an eye to
understanding issues that are very very
relevant to public policy and how we do
things going forward so I think it's a
fun one let's go
[Music]
thank you
Brooke Harrington welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you for having
me I'm so excited to speak with you the
reason we're here in some sense the sort
of intellectual draw is that you've
written a paper that talks about of all
things offshore Wealth Management
Systems as a complex system and uh you
know the words complex system get me
very excited and so forth but I think
there's a lot of groundwork to lay
before we get to the complex system side
of things so tell us what is a wealth
manager I don't have one myself I
probably probably don't need one
probably not many professors do
well I'm a wealth manager okay
congratulations you could be a wealth
manager if you wanted to be it's a it's
a profession that has existed for
centuries but it wasn't professional
lives until recently so until maybe a
decade ago you couldn't go to college to
study to be one
um people just did it and and now you
can get a credential which is what I did
after about two years of study it's sort
of like one year of an MBA program plus
one year of law school but very
specialized needs and interests of
people who have like 50 million or more
investable assets
so one of the one of the people I
interviewed for the eight-year study I
conducted of offshore wealth managers
said you know that's it's one of the
most complex professions in the world
because the technical requirements to do
it well combine law and Finance and
Accounting
um and a certain amount of like what you
might call political science just like
assessing out what the the likely
political atmosphere and different
offshore centers might be and if if it's
going to be stable
um because you don't want to put your
clients fortune in a country whose
regime might topple at any minute like
you don't want their assets to be
confiscated or nationalized in some way
uh but also there's a a non-negotiable
element of emotional intelligence that
goes into it too and you can't really
teach that but independently
um two wealth managers I worked with
said I'm a social worker for the rich
meaning themselves and these were highly
credentialed professionals
um who had law degrees or mbas and they
said well ultimately money is just very
emotional what they meant by that is
that when you're a wealth manager your
job is to protect the client's Fortune
to grow it somewhat but when you're
wealthy enough to afford a wealth
manager and to use offshore Finance
um often what you really want is simply
to protect what you have from the
various forces that might diminish your
assets which include
taxation uh debts so the same people who
don't like to pay their taxes also don't
like to pay their debts and there are
high-end bounty hunters who chase these
people around wealthy folks who who
don't like paying their debts also have
a bad habit of bragging about their
locations on Instagram
so a few years ago the Wall Street
Journal ran a really interesting article
on a friend of mine who is a very high
powered lawyer who was based in London
at the time and basically all he did was
follow the Instagram accounts of
oligarchs and as soon as they came to
the UK or particularly to London they
would post some photo of themselves at
clairages or something and he'd be like
right to his team and he'd send them to
claridges to the smoking room to serve
these individuals with the legal papers
necessary to to start the lawsuits to
reclaim whatever it was they owed to my
friends clients
so taxes and debts threaten a person's
Fortune so do uh disgruntled heirs
divorcing spouses
um any kind of inquiring uh press
coverage could be a threat so your job
as a wealth manager sort of be a
bodyguard for the money not so much the
client the client brings you the money
and you have to protect it from being
chipped away at by those various forces
I've mentioned and it's it's
surprisingly complex like you never ever
put all the fortune in one place you
spread it out like confetti yeah across
different countries often for good
reason like different countries compete
with each other to have laws that
protect specific kinds of assets or or
do certain kinds of things like some
countries specialize in protecting
assets like Yachts others
specialize in allowing you to register
your private jet without tax right
others like the Cook Islands they they
don't provide tax avoidance at all they
provide um
debt avoidance so one person I talk to a
wealth manager have a client who had
taken a half million dollar loan from
Bank of America
sucked it away in a Cook Islands asset
protection trust declared bankruptcy and
said oh sorry back for America I can't
pay you back
and Bank of America knowing what was up
in the Cook Islands which which is to
say that that country has established
what's called firewall legislation
saying that if you're a foreigner who
comes there claiming any right to Assets
in in the trust under Cook Islands law
you face extremely hostile legislation
that puts all the burden of proof on you
and that disfavors you in the eyes of
the law so no force on Earth even the US
government has been able to break
through a Cook Islands asset for taxi
trust so Bank of America kind of went uh
forget it Jake it's Chinatown I just
walked away from it holy smokes uh so
okay good that gives us a flavor I like
that uh I mean presumably look I know
some people think that there shouldn't
be any such thing as wealthy people and
that is absolutely an attitude to have
my attitude is I'm very in favor of
wealthy people I wish I were one myself
I just want them to pay taxes and to pay
their debts and then we can use those
those resources services but if you
think that wealthy people existing is
not bad then I imagine there is up
benign side to wealth management right I
mean you know retirement planning or
investment planning or whatever but then
there's also clearly the Shady Side I
mean it's a very unfair question but is
there a fraction that you can give to
sort of how much of this is just
responsible money management and how
much of it is trying to sneak around the
rules well I say a lot of it now has
just become a very elaborate form of
cheating cheating of capitalism cheating
on the row of law
um so the problem isn't wealthy people
wealthy people have existed long before
there was an offshore Financial system
sure so the existence of wealthy people
isn't a problem that I'm pointing out
um the the problem is that some people
can buy their way out of the sort of
basic
um
Mutual responsibilities that keep
Society functioning and and they're what
sociologists call Free Riders yeah are
you familiar with that phrase very much
yes like everyone who's ever done a
group project no sort of free writer is
and everyone hates the free writer right
they're like the certain group of people
in a group project who actually do all
the work and then the free writers their
real skill is figuring out how to game
the group project so that they get
maximum reward for as little effort as
possible
another way of describing what offshore
does is it permits people to to certain
people to sort of dine and dash on
society you know that phrase from if you
ever worked in a restaurant dining Dash
is when people customers come in and
they eat and then they just skip out on
the bill yeah common in uh in large
parties you know a group who comes into
a restaurant and then right racks up you
know a couple thousand dollars in
charges and then one or two people just
sneak off to the powder room and never
come back leaving others to pay a share
I think that's pretty universally
frowned upon and that is essentially
what the offshore system allows certain
people to do okay yes there are benign
uses for it
um for example when when I was going
around the world interviewing wealth
managers in in places like Mauritius
which is an island in the middle of the
Indian Ocean some of the the wealth
managers I spoke to there said well you
know there really wouldn't be any
foreign direct investment in Africa
without us like virtually all the wealth
that goes from India to Africa passes
through Mauritius at some point why
because Indian investors don't want to
plunk their money down in like
Mozambique where they they may not speak
Portuguese they they may not be
confident that the regime there is
stable
um they want to protect their assets by
putting them in say Mauritius trusts or
Mauritius corporations because they
understand this English common law which
was in Mauritius as well as it was in
India and there's a there's a sense of
security like they can deal with us
they're not so sure they can deal with
some of the government's of the
countries that they'll be investing in
so that is an argument that one hears
um that foreign direct investment is
dependent upon the offshore system you
also hear from people who are developing
countries well I can't trust the the
government of my own country because if
uh if there's regime change if there's
any kind of instability like a political
assassination I don't know what happens
to my Assets in this country the safest
thing for me and my family is to get
them offshore so often this individually
rational decision to want to get your
own wealth offshore the Russian
oligarchs that we studied have this
dilemma too on the one hand many of them
looted and pillaged their own Society
on the other hand maybe some of them
made their their Fortunes in the honest
ways but Russia is also a country where
if you say the wrong combination of
words at the wrong time you might find
yourself facing a 10-year sentence in
the gulag like like Mikhail karorovsky
did so there's a very real possibility
of assets being confiscated you being
jailed your family being faced with
reprisals so for many people from
autocratic societies putting their
assets offshore as their insurance
policy and by the way they also get
themselves offshore by getting
themselves and their family members
foreign passports or even a whole new
nationality right oh yeah it's it's very
common for people in this Echelon of
society to have two three four
nationalities and then you pick the one
that is has the law that is best suited
to your present purposes
that's exactly right
so for example in last a year ago one of
the ways that um Roman Abramovich was
able to avoid some EU sanctions on
himself was that uh the EU cannot
sanction its own systems or citizens of
its member states weeks before then
Abramovich has secured himself a
Portuguese passport there you go and the
the case of Mauritius and the Cook
Islands and so forth is an interesting
one where small countries have
intentionally chosen to make themselves
into favorable locations for this
offshore wealth wealth management it's a
little bit it's kind of a venue shopping
right like there are states in the
United States where the tax laws are
looser you know corporate protections or
greater whatever what is the what is the
thought process behind being the Cook
Islands or whatever and saying yes we're
gonna be a Haven for a lot of wealth
passing through it's the easiest way to
pump up a struggling economy because it
requires almost zero infrastructure
investment all you you have to have is
working telephone lines
um an internet connection electricity
and hopefully generally an
English-speaking population helps but
their whole offshore centers like Panama
that cater specifically to
Spanish-speaking populations or
traditionally Hong Kong cater to Chinese
speaking populations
um
the the story of how countries become
offshore Financial Centers or even how
American states become offshore centers
like South Dakota and Wyoming Nevada and
Delaware is one of places that are
economically fragile they're they're
generally small they may not have a lot
going for them
um like South Dakota used to be fairly
prosperous just on its agricultural
production but it can't be now and so it
needs some way to pump up its its tax
base and you know keep the lights on in
the state of South Dakota and so they
just borrowed the strategy that lots of
decolonizing countries adopted 50 years
ago and in fact it was pushed on a lot
of decolonizing countries because the
what are called the colonial metropols
the centers of colonialism like London
or Paris they didn't want to have to
financially support these ancient call
colonies you know they they were like uh
kids who failed to launch it's like okay
you want to be independent that's great
but if you want to live with us you've
got to pay rent or you know go get a job
and so these former Colonial Powers said
to their former colonies get a job and
you know what are you gonna do if you're
a little mosquito infested spit of sand
in the middle of the Caribbean as the
Cayman Islands were I mean literally no
one wanted to go there because the
mosquito problem was so bad it was a
disaster and most of the men able-bodied
men were they left to be in the fishing
industry and they were sailing all over
the world so there wasn't much left
there except women and children and
mosquitoes
and now it's one of the biggest tax
payments in the world
um because some enterprising people
from other colonies like Canada or in
the case of the Cayman Islands it was a
guy named William Walker who was born in
what used to be called British Guiana
and he he was sort of a a colonial Elite
who went and took another post-colonial
place and brought it into the into the
financial world
so they people like Walker built those
places up
um by establishing very basic things
like Pest Control phone lines Office
Buildings and he he brought over some
people from the UK and from Canada and
he trained locals and out of those
rather humble beginnings almost like a
like a garage band or like you know HP
starting up in their Garage on pageville
road
um he built this thing that became a a
juggernaut in the financial world
and that that became a model for a lot
of other small struggling post-colonial
countries because places like the Cayman
Islands and the British Virgin Islands
have some of the highest standards of
living in the world largely because they
are these conduits for billions probably
trillions of corporate and private
wealth now and other small countries
like Mauritius or the Seychelles or the
Cook Islands they see that and they're
like we need that and it's not that
difficult to do in terms of investment
to get started just as a little uh
personal color I do want the audience
members to hear the story of how you
became an embedded journalist on the
thought that maybe the wealth managers
of the world who are doing some shady
things for secretive people wouldn't
want to talk to a sociologist you came
up with a an unusual strategy so I
wasn't a journalist I have been a
journalist before like when before I
went to graduate school I was but this
is different I was what's called a an
ethnographer which is a technique that
comes from anthropology and has been
adopted by other fields it basically
what you do is you go you go live among
the population you want to study you
stay with them long term and You observe
them and you see what you can find and
this is a very important technique for
groups of people who don't wish to be
studied who are either very remote or
very secretive and suspicious or all of
the above
so
the my previous work was on American
investors in a domestic context
um if anyone listening remembers the
Beardstown ladies or investment clubs
from the 1990s oh yeah I studied
investment clubs because there was a
point in the late 90s early 2000s when
of non-incarcerated American adults
belong to an investment club which is
just a mind-boggling number
so that actually studying how
individuals who are not Finance experts
decide to invest their money as a
collective turned out to be pretty
interesting
and and that was actually the the first
sort of complex system work that I ever
did that's what got me to SFI way back I
think it was 2003 or 2004. but in the
course of doing that research
um I discovered that like beyond the
middle class Echelon that I had been
investigating there were these these
further astronauts that I could just
barely see were people who really had a
lot of money they weren't messing around
like the Beardstown ladies they had a
more bespoke kind of solution to the
problem of of doing something with their
wealth protecting it growing it Etc and
I knew a little bit about that because I
happened to grow up in a wealthy suburb
of Chicago where the kind of people who
had wealth managers lived and sent their
kids to public schools and they ended up
sitting next to Middle Class B in you
know French class
so I know these people existed and I
started thinking how can I study this
because while all these middle class
folks are puttering away in their
investment clubs there's this whole
other world they don't even know about
where you can make a lot more money you
have access to much more profitable
Investments and also a lot more
protection against downside risk how do
I get funding to study that how would I
even get it so for years I turned over
in my head how I can persuade the
National Science Foundation to fund me
to like go live among the ultra rich and
and study their ways
um and I thought you know they're never
gonna buy this you know I probably could
do it I'm a sailor and I thought if I
just turn up at the Harvard Monte Carlo
or something when they when they're
showing off their their Yachts like
maybe I could crew or maybe I if I got a
fancy enough trust I could just walk
walk on there and like show up at a
cocktail party and and fake it till I
made it exactly but I just I couldn't
figure out a way to pitch that to the
NSF or any American Funding organization
with a straight face but fortunately I I
was invited
um in 2006.
to do a sabbatical year at the one of
the max Pike institutes in Germany so I
thought I was just going for a year to
do some research and not have to teach
or do administrative work
I got there and found out that the guy
who ran that particular Max plank
Institute had just published a big book
on inherited wealth he was interested in
the same things I was he got why I
wanted to study the ultra wealthy and
best of all he was in charge of a 2
million euro budget annually that he
could sprinkle like fairy dusts on
anyone who wrote him a plausible three
to five page memo and I'm like this is
the Promised Land
so being
um young and unindebted and not having a
family to support at the time I was like
you know what I'm staying so so I stayed
instead of going back to Brown where I
was an assistant professor or going back
to the US at all I just stayed in Europe
and I I found that European funding
agencies are much more open-minded about
funding um truly high-risk research and
I built on the money that the max Pike
Institute gave me to get some more
funding from other German institutions
but the the real sort of moment of
breakthrough was was sort of thinking
about what Matt's Weber had said about
the role of expertise and how
so much of the world really depends on
on Experts like there are people who
benefit from the expertise like the
clients of wealth managers but even I
knew that ultra wealthy people they're
not sitting around on their Yachts
phoning up on the tax code of the Cayman
Islands they have people to do that just
like they have people to pick up their
dry cleaning and clean their houses and
I thought well the viberian strategy
here is study the experts because
they're the ones who are really making
the offshore World habit if you want to
look at wealth inequality which is what
interested me don't look at the people
who just benefit from it look at the
people who make it you know with their
own two hands I thought huh I wonder if
there is a place where I could go study
the experts and I knew there was a
professor at MIT named John vanmann
who's worked as sort of a must read for
sociology grad students because he's
sort of a god of qualitative methodology
he made his name as a graduate student
in Southern California in the late 60s
right after the Watts Riots not all
listeners may know what that was but it
was a it was a racially motivated police
brutality Riot that tore apart Los
Angeles and Southern California and sort
of became a touchstone for civil unrest
based on racism and police brutality so
John vanmann was a graduate student in
Southern California right around that
time and he decided he wanted to study
the police so he wrote a series of
polite letters as one was supposed to do
to local police departments say hi I'm a
graduate student in Social biology and I
would like to Shadow your officers to
study how the police work and every
single door was slammed in his face
because the suspicion between police on
the one hand and civilians on the other
especially like allegedly long-haired
hippie graduate students in sociology it
it just was never going to work and a
normal person would have given up at
that point and found something else to
do their dissertation on but John Van
manen was dogged and he was like you
know what
I've got time I'm a graduate student I'm
just gonna walk down to the police
academy and enroll and they can't stop
me
so he did and then he went through the
police academy he he went around on
patrol armed with other police he didn't
lie to anyone he didn't say you know I'm
really I really want to be a police
officer he's going to use a fake name he
told everyone that he encountered who he
was and why he was there and the idea
was the hope was that he would gain
enough of their Respect by trying to put
his feet in their shoes that they would
at least consent to talk with him or to
let him see what the world was like and
it worked and it yielded some some
really legendary uh Publications and the
rest is history so I realized I could do
that too and pretty much for the same
reason wealth managers are not just
Bound by our a professional Norm of
discretion in many places like
Switzerland if you're a wealth manager
and you're found to have disclosed any
identifying information about one of
your clients even by accident or in
passing you face not only civil charges
with criminal charges so they're very
strong incentives for people like that
never ever to talk to people like me so
really my only option was to join them
so I did what the Amanda did I found the
place you go to get a credential on
wealth management and luckily for me
there's really only one place you could
do it that's globally recognized an
organization called step in London is
sort of the the global professional
Society for wealth managers and they
offer the most globally recognized
credential just this two-year thing I I
mentioned to you so I enrolled and I got
the money to do it from German funding
sources and even they were kind of
skeptical I didn't know if I could get
these people to talk to me but I figured
I'm going to show up and try I've got
nothing to lose and I'm never going to
get this chance again so I'm going for
it and lo and behold once I was in these
five day a week nine to five classes
with practicing wealth managers like
anywhere between like a dozen and Shifty
other people
um they did talk to me they talked to
each other and I listened in when I
approached them and asked them if they
would be willing to speak to me
unconditional anonymity like in other
words I wouldn't even write down their
names much less whom they they worked
for and I was going to ask them
questions that wouldn't get them in
trouble like nothing about individual
clients for example many of them were
very willing to speak to me because this
is my theory a couple things one is I
looked enough like them that I didn't
trigger any sort of knee-jerk distrust
or fear
most wealth managers are still I would
say at least 70 percent are white upper
middle class English-speaking people
most of men but like
I blended in well enough
um there are many many situations where
I couldn't have just parachuted in and
studied a group like I just would have
looked too different to to not arouse
suspicion or to to engender enough trust
that people would be willing to speak to
me but this was a a hote Bourgeois
professional group so I could just kind
of slide on in there yep I could walk
the walk the other thing was that I I
didn't realize how much people in the
wealth management industry as as well
compensated as they are they feel very
aggrieved and misunderstood that they
don't have any Outlets to express that
or defend themselves because of these
Norms of confidentiality so they did all
this pent up anger about being portrayed
as the bad guys of the International
Financial world and you know their
families have probably had an earful
about it and are bored to death
so have their colleagues so who's left I
come along I'm not a colleague I'm not a
family member I'm I'm credentialed so I
know enough about what they're talking
about that they don't have to explain
every third word I can ask intelligent
questions so it turned out that when
people were willing to speak to me the
biggest problem I faced oftentimes was
giving them to stop talking
one guy only we only ended our interview
because the cafe we were sitting in
closed after three and a half hours wow
I mean that is the level of sort of
confessional or unloading that I was
experiencing so it was awesome from a
data perspective and I think there's
probably many things let's tell the
audience that you wrote a book so tell
them what the uh title of your book was
because I don't have in front of me so
after about eight years of this uh
immersive field research called
ethnography where I went all over the
world I got I got my credential to be a
wealth manager and then I used that that
was my ticket to go to professional
Society meetings and wealth management
because you you can't just go to them
you have to prove that you're one of
them first then you pay the fee and you
go so I ended up going to 18 offshore
Financial Centers all over the world and
speaking with and observing 65 wealth
managers at work so for a qualitative
study of a secretive group that's a lot
it took about eight years partly because
getting the funding together to go to
Crazy remote places like the Cook
Islands which is roughly between Fiji
and Tahiti that's hard it's very time
consuming anyways uh after about eight
years of that I published a book in 2016
called Capital Without Borders and that
came out roughly six months after the
Panama papers broke which was like one
of the biggest Strokes of luck I've ever
experienced in my entire life it was
like the ultimate PR campaign it put
offshore finance and off for cheating on
everybody's radar so I I had no idea it
was coming and you know when I was
reviewing the galleys for Capital
Without Borders kaboo it just dropped it
dropped like a happy bomb and right into
the news and and ever since then there
have just been more leaks and things
like the sanctions on Russian oligarchs
continually keeping offshore Finance
relevance And Timely and there's like I
was going to say there's a whole bunch
of interesting things in the book we
could talk about but I just want to
because I want to get to the complex
systems business but the one thing I
can't let go of is the the attitude that
wealth managers have toward their
clients which is which is divided right
like there are some who are very
resentful that they're doing all this
work for these these wealthy people but
there's others who are cheerleaders
apologists for the for the people that
they're working for yeah yeah I think
General's phenomenon it's not just that
like everybody every job has people who
love the job and are met about the job
and and some group who hate it
um the people I interviewed I would
divide into to three main categories
probably about one-fourth of of the
wealth managers I spoke with were what
you might call hardcore libertarian
um
anarcho-capitalists who honestly
believed that taxes theft that basically
government in general is is a dubious
proposition yeah except in so far as
Government enforces the contracts and
protects the private property of their
clients otherwise nah right
um and those are the people who would
tell me you know I I protect my clients
who are wealth creators from the
rapacious and illegitimate confiscation
of out of control welfare states
and they would say it with an absolutely
straight face they weren't having me on
it was they believed it and so my job as
a as a sociologist was just to sit
non-politely and let them explain their
views about 50 of the people I
interviewed
they kind of they made a not very
satisfying moral compromise in which
they said what I love about my job is
that I help families
no that's exactly well that's true they
do help families it's just a partial
truth and it's a very carefully crafted
partial truth which they knew and I knew
and they knew that I knew right
um
the partial truth the what they were
excluding was they were helping a small
group with families at the expense of
all other families and you know it's I'm
not even wagging a figure at these folks
far from it everybody no not everybody
many people make moral compromises in
the work they do you know I do oh yeah I
went from eight years of teaching at
Copenhagen business school which is a
one of Denmark's eight public
universities there are no private
universities in Denmark
um and when I was teaching there I knew
for sure that every single student I saw
was there because of their Merit because
there is no such thing as a tuition fee
so I wasn't part of reproducing an elite
that had unfair advantages over anyone
else I really was helping to build a
country in a way like I was training the
best and the brightest of this country
it just wasn't my country so I come back
to this wonderful job at Dartmouth and
it it feels a little weird even though I
am a product of the ID League system you
know Stanford and Harvard and brown
um
so I I know it's it's just very obvious
from looking around their money plays a
big role in who gets in to a place like
Dartmouth it doesn't play the only role
and I'm not saying the students that I
teach don't have any Merit at all they
do many of them are brilliant
um but there's there's a distortion
happening because of the fact that
tuition at Dartmouth is just North of
seventy thousand dollars a year that
creates a different Dynamic than than I
experienced at a tuition-free public
university and I know that I'm part of
it as a sociologist it would be very
dishonest for me to avoid confronting
that so so I make moral compromises with
that fact just the way wealth managers
who have mortgages and kids school fees
and and you know careers that they've
invested decades in they make their
moral compromises so I'm not putting
this out there as much standing in
Judgment of them I'm I'm just trying to
observe and analyze what they're telling
me there's another quarter of the the
group I interviewed and I have no way of
knowing in a sample size of 50 or 65 how
representative this is of the whole
population of wealth managers but in the
group that I interviewed 25 were these
sort of Hardcore Libertarians about 50
percent were were the people who made
this I help families compromise but then
to me very interesting other 25 percent
were people who were very out out and
explicit about their discomfort with the
nature of their own work and they were
struggling they were telling me about
the struggle that they had with it so
one fellow I interviewed who was
actually at mosa Fonseca in Panama City
several years before the Panama papers
broke
he he said to me
look I I I used to be involved in social
justice causes I didn't get into the law
to serve rich people quite the contrary
I got into the law to serve indigenous
people and poor people and basically my
employer tapped me for a project that
got me sucked into working with some of
the the company's wealthiest clients and
I turned out to be good at it so they
just kept me on and it bothers me
because here I am talking to some of the
world's wealthiest people but a mile
away there are people living under
bridges in cardboard boxes so what do I
do with that I want my son to be able to
look at me and and feel some respect the
way I could look at my own father so he
says this is what I do I figure I've got
the ear of these people nobody else
talks to them about poverty and
inequality I'm going to take the risk
and if they fire me they fire me so he
said you know I talked to them about the
people living under bridges in cardboard
boxes and I urge them to think about
what they might do with their wealth to
help those people or other people
similarly situated elsewhere in the
world and often they look at me like
like I have three heads but no one's
fired me yet so I'm going to keep doing
it
so there were there were several people
like that who they had a plan and I
wonder sometimes when a new leak comes
out was that someone I interviewed yeah
if not it it they're part of this cohort
of wealth managers or insiders who have
similar qualms about the nature of their
work and its effect on the world and
this is the way they deal with it they
they leverage the fact that they are on
the inside either to try and persuade
clients one person at a time or to make
these big Anonymous leaks that pull the
lid off the whole thing I think that
that's legit I think you need all kinds
of people you need people protesting on
the outside you need people on the
inside trying to make things a little
bit better I'm not I'm also not going to
judge anybody that way one way or the
other but um let me be clear let me
let's clarify one thing because we've
been talking about wealth managers and
we've been talking about the offshore
wealth management system are they
synonymous I mean I presume they're just
on sure wealth managers as well but
we're we're in particular today talking
about the offshore system is that right
yes so I mean what what led you to to
invite me on this show is this this
article that I I produced with with
colleagues at Brown and I'm sorry I hit
Dartmouth
um to mathematics professors Dan
rockmore and Feng Fu and our first
author Herbert Chang who is just
finishing up his dissertation at USC
Annenberg and is about to join us as a
professor of quantitative social science
at Dartmouth so
what we worked on is the system the
complex system created by wealth
managers so wealth managers are the
experts but they they designed and and
they manage and they they keep up and
running this complex system that's built
on the ashes of mostly British
colonialism I was I was very interested
when you dropped in into the paper the
fact that so much of this is a colonial
Legacy like the the ex-colonies really
are what you need if you want to have a
efficient offshore wealth management
system
yes and that's mostly because of the
legal system that the British left
behind because there are things you can
do in the common law tradition that you
can't do in other legal traditions and
that you need those things in order to
play what what legal Scholars call the
Shell game of ownership where you know
those little shell games that people
play with Walnut shells and like ball
bearings on street corners so a lot of
what happens offshore is instead of
Walnut shells you have uh structures
like truss or corporations or
foundations and then you move the ball
bearing which is the client's fortune or
a particular asset you move that that
asset around under the dose different
legal structures and you make it very
difficult to ascertain well who really
owns that structure if it's in a trust
the trustee owns it that's usually the
wealth manager if it's in a company well
you that that company can be owned by a
trust and a foundation this is what
ingvar compra the the creator of Ikea
did he he didn't want to pay Swedish
taxes so he used the law of the
Netherlands to create an offshore
Financial structure that basically
envelops Ikea in a in what is ostensibly
a charitable Foundation except it
doesn't really ever give away money it
just enables him to control the firm and
pay his kids a salary without paying
normal corporate tax
so what fraction like if I am a person
I'm not if I were a person that had 50
million dollars or more to invest uh it
does most of that go offshore or is
there is like the only the Uber Elites
that really dominate that market
well to get a wealth manager even to
give you the time of day you'd have to
have at least 5 million U.S in
investable assets and that means not
just your net worth but your net worth
not including your primary Investments
right so when you narrow it down like
that you're talking about a couple
million people worldwide but that that's
sort of the absolute bottom of the
barrel that's when it would be you and
maybe nine other people sharing a wealth
manager yeah and as you have more wealth
to invest you're more and more likely to
get like bespoke services from a wealth
manager it's kind of like the analogy I
would use is for clothing you know
there's there's off the rack clothing
that you could buy at Target or
um Saks Fifth Avenue and then there's
hot Couture which is what you see
walking down the runway in Paris and
that say Christian Dior will make on
your body
specific to your measurements for like
twenty thousand dollars for a ball gown
or something
and in between there's a there's a kind
of clothing called Preta Forte which are
these sort of very special designer
lines that you wouldn't find uh for sale
at Target they're not bespoke to your
body but they're much closer to to the
runway so if you're coming in with five
million dollars in investable assets
you're essentially buying wealth
management off the rack from Target a
lot better than nothing but that's very
entry level if you're the kind of person
who has 50 million dollars or more
you're getting the the wealth management
equivalents of Couture you probably have
what's called a family office which is
not just a wealth manager but several
wealth managers who do nothing but work
for you and your family yeah and then in
between in that gray area between 5 and
50 you have the finance equivalent of
pretaporte where you maybe you share
wealth manager with like three or four
other people but it's it's very
personalized and you know in capital
without orders I talk about these these
crazy stories where wealth managers
would tell me yeah my client called me
from like Zurich I was in London and she
said I've lost my bracelet outside this
restaurant in Zurich help me find it
and as a wealth manager they can't say
what are you insane find it yourself
call the police how can I find something
in a different country but no if you're
a wealth manager you just that's your
job you work it out yeah and that's the
kind of personalization I'm talking must
be frustrating to be the person with 10
million dollars in extra money and still
not really be at the upper level of what
you can get in this business well you
know that is a super interesting point
Sean I'm really glad you raised this
because a lot of what I see sort of in
popular discourse is people asking about
the rich why do they never have enough
you know why do people like Bezos and
musk and Branson have to get their their
rocket projects and compete with each
other over like who launched this first
like what is their problem why can't
they just like go get themselves some
you know cocktail with a little umbrella
in it and lay back on their yacht and
enjoy themselves why are they always
fighting with each other and more and
more and more this is the reason because
no group of people competes with the
entire universe of other people for
status in sociology we call this the
problem of reference groups We Choose Or
are given in in life certain reference
groups against which we compare
ourselves family neighborhood school
friends and now because of social media
we have lots of other groups we can
choose as our reference groups like fans
of Kim Kardashian so those are the
yardsticks we use to measure our status
and so while we may be I don't know
compared to the universe of people in
the world well paid well off we're not
going to feel well paid well off or high
status unless we're doing well compared
to our reference so the reference group
for people with 10 million dollars is
other people with 10 million dollars or
more and it's the or more that eats away
of them at night yeah
Academia could tell exactly the same
story couldn't exactly yes it's like Oh
I'm a full tenure Professor but I don't
have an endowed chair right yes that's
how that's how we are it's all it's all
human beings all the way down but okay
let's put ourselves in the world of the
of the very tiny tip of the iceberg
where they all have their bespoke
offshore wealth managers what you did in
the new paper is think about that system
as a complex Network so there are nodes
and there are connections so let's bring
it down to earth what are the nodes and
what are the connections what is the
network that we're talking about here
the network is this complex structure
that wealth managers have created in the
offshore world so what we were able to
look at using the the leaked data that
has has come to light through the 2016
Panama papers the 2017 Panama papers let
me backtrack a bit so that the Panama
paper in 2016 was a cache of data from
one company it was 40 Years of data from
the company called mossack Fonseca it
was a law firm in Panama City Panama so
somebody on the inside there dumped a
ton of data
and that was followed in 2017 by the
paradise papers which came from a
company called Applebee's in Bermuda
which is also a law firm a wealth
management law firm and then I believe
Asia City trust which I can't remember
where that is but it was it was two
countries and then you may remember in
2020 there was the Pandora papers which
involved I'm going to get the strong is
it 14 companies or 14 countries I think
there's at least a dozen countries so it
was much more spread out than either
Panama or Paradise papers but still very
incomplete we have no idea how
representative any of these links are
these leaks are of the whole universe of
wealth management offshore activity but
they're all we've got because otherwise
this data is completely held in secret
there's no way to know who holds what
offshore
all of this information went to an
organization called the international
Consortium of investigative journalists
and they strip out a lot of identifying
information like in these leaks where
things like uh images of passports of
the clients their home addresses really
really sensitive identifying stuff so
icij goes in they strip out all of that
identifying stuff and they make the rest
publicly available online anyone can
find it we took this data me Herbert Dan
and Feng and we tried to figure out okay
knowing that this is very incomplete and
patchy is there anything that we can
make of this that would be useful so I
had a bunch of ideas I wanted to test
and here was the quantitative data to
test it with I reached out to them
because I don't have the skills to do
this level of network analysis like I've
done quantitative work before I
published a lot of like laboratory
experiments using econometric methods
that like Network size of complexity
that's a whole different animal yeah
there's some specialized knowledge there
called in the experts good
um and their their mathematicians and
computer scientists and luckily for me
they were willing to climb this very
steep learning curve to learn enough
about offshore finance that we could
have a conversation about what the data
what the data were in these icij
publicly available sets because you
can't just like open up what the icij
makes available and instantly grasp what
they're showing you oh no
hahaha
I think that's one of the reasons there
hasn't been as much research based on
offshore leaks as there might have been
because it's an incredibly deep rich
resource I think like something like a
total of 10 terabytes worth of data just
enormous the problem is to make head or
tail of it you have to be able to look
at it and know what what's an
intermediary yeah what's a beneficiary
what's a trust and and just getting
there is it's a it's a big leap so I had
that information and I had a series of
testable propositions derived from my
qualitative research here was the data
here were people who could work with the
data and we had to kind of meet in the
middle to learn to speak each other's
language across disciplines well enough
that we could make something of it and
as as I was telling you at the at the
the top of this podcast just this
morning I ran across an article of
nature by my old grad school pal James
Evans who's a sociologist at the
University of Chicago talking about how
the most high impact research tends to
be when when Scholars cross the streams
of disciplines like disciplines that
normally are not in conversation with
each other at all and that's definitely
the case with sociology and math and
network science although there are
plenty of quantitative sociologists the
level of what Herbert and Dan and Frank
can do is is far beyond what most
sociologists except people like James
Evans actually do so what we were able
to do in the the pnas Nexus paper
was to use this sort of frustratingly
incomplete data to map out the
relationships or the the web of
relationships between clients of
offshore that is the wealthy people and
their wealth managers and the structures
that those wealth managers create for
them in different places
and from that we began to observe some
very interesting and unexpected patterns
like
um wow this seems to behave like a
scale-free network and ha wealthy people
from different parts of the world such
as Russia and China and the United
States and Hong Kong and very different
patterns of relationship to both wealth
managers and offshore structures now
this was very gratifying to me because
that's exactly what my qualitative
research suggested we would find but I'd
never been able to test that until we
sort of did the laborious work of
combing through this data and testing it
it's a good feeling
it's a great feeling similarly I I
received a pretty good quantity of
anecdotal data from wealth managers
working with Russian and Chinese clients
saying look they're really different
what they want is different they have
different needs because of the because
of the political environment they come
from they need different things from us
and from the offshore system in general
that clients from Europe or the Americas
might be tell us to hear some specific
oh could you could you just tell us in
very simple terms I'm sure that most the
listeners here know what a scale free
network is but let's assume that they
don't like it what does it mean to say
that this network that you've drawn
between clients and managers and
structures is scale free I think if I
were explaining this to some of my
undergraduates and say well some
networks are very easy to break down
but others are robust kind of like like
Fabrics like the The netting that you
see on like a wedding veil like you
could you can tear that with your
fingertips really easily that's not a
robust fabric you can see it's a little
network of of threads or fibers that
connect to one another but it's not
robust there are Fabrics like like rip
stop or or Gore-Tex where not only could
you tear at it with your fingers but you
know you could you could take like a
relatively sharp object and and try and
tear away at it without succeeding there
are certain networks that are composed
more like that that's really hard to
tear them apart or break the connections
a scale-free network comes across like a
piece of ripstop or Gore-Tex it seems
unbreakable but if you know about the
properties of the fiber you can find
ways to break it the World Wide Web is
composed like this it's very robust but
if you know where to attack you can make
it break down there's some Gene editing
networks in animals that work the same
way so scale free network has this
really interesting property that it it's
robust to random attacks so if you just
start like tearing at it randomly it's
not going to break but if you know where
the vulnerabilities are which which are
these highly connected nodes like hubs
like in a like an airport Hub and spokes
system and if you strike there yeah then
you can make either the whole thing fall
apart or big parts of it so everyone who
has tried to like fly through Chicago or
Newark during winter storm season or
summer thunderstorm season knows how
this works if if your Hub gets attacked
or or it gets pulled out of out of
service
everyone's flights are disrupted that's
the kind of network that we're seeing in
the offshore world except instead of the
hubs being Chicago or Newark the hubs
are certain wealth managers who have a
lot of very wealthy clients who all
cluster their business around this or
that person I really like the two the
combination of the two metaphors of
fabric and the airline Network because
it it draws on the difference between a
scale free network and something like a
lattice right like if the airline
Network in the United States were like a
fabric where everything is just
connected nearby to get 3 000 miles you
might have to take uh
30 trips of 100 miles each right but
because it is scale free and these long
range connections you can get there in
in two trips and so you're saying that
the offshore Financial network is that
kind of thing there are some hubs
they're really super duper connected and
then there's some smaller hubs and then
below that even smaller hubs yeah and
you know I alluded to the fact that my
my informants in the qualitative study
had told me that
um although wealthy people ultra wealthy
people from all over the world have a
lot in common with each other sometimes
more in common with each other than with
the people of their own countries there
remain very significant National
differences that are driven both by
culture and by politics and so for
example apparently with Chinese clients
you cannot speak to them about death
it's just a taboo topic which is very
awkward because a lot of what a wealth
manager does is plan for things like
succession I was going to say yeah what
happens if if you have a client as is
common a Chinese client who has created
a very um a very wealthy family business
how do you have the conversation about
okay so whom do you want to take over
and uh who gets your stuff now imagine
trying to have that conversation if you
can't say words like death or die
tricky huh right
um similarly clients from autocratic
societies
tend to be understandably extremely
distrustful and when they find someone
usually through Word of Mouth whom they
regard as trustworthy everyone wants to
work with that person you see this a
little bit if you read magazines in the
grocery store checkout line like you
know people are in touch like all the
celebs like to go to the same
hairdresser or the same plastic surgeon
why because the person is not just
competent at their job they may also
have a reputation for having the best
bedside manner or or the most reliable
discretion or whatever
the people who go to wealth managers for
offshore financial services are no
different they they use Word of Mouth
they don't go the Yellow Pages to find a
wealth manager they use whoever their
friends use and if if they come from
autocratic societies they tend to have
very few people whose opinion and Word
of Mouth they could trust and so that
creates these Hubbard spoke effects
where lots of say Russian oligarchs or
Chinese oligarchs end up using the same
wealth managers and this makes that in
turn create that creates the
vulnerability in the system because if
you can take that Hub out of commission
by say sanctioning the wealth manager so
they can't work with sanctioned
oligarchs that disrupts the system as a
whole and this makes perfect sense in
terms of why you would want to borrow
expertise from complex systems studies
because that makes perfect sense to
someone who studies networks and complex
systems when you see scale-free Behavior
because not all networks are scale free
but you want to understand what is the
mechanism why does it have the scale
free behavior and one of the most
obvious ones is preferential attachment
the rich get richer and so the good
wealth managers get their Word of Mouth
shared around and they're going to get
more clients that way exactly and it's
clear from your paper that a lot of the
motivation here is very policy driven so
you know even though it's complex
systems and fun academic intellectual
ideas at the end of the day how does
this tell us what better policies to
implement in particular you were
motivated by the fact that some of these
people are from regimes which can be bad
actors and we might want to sanction
them someday and how do we do that
effectively well there's this long
tradition of sanctioning the transfer of
information and people who can transfer
it and it started at least in the 1940s
with the nuclear program and then
extended to things like bioweapons and
so forth so if you happen to work in any
of those areas where you might be privy
to nuclear secrets or to information
about how to manufacture or use chemical
weapons you're subject to a lot of
restrictions on whom you can talk to
what you can say and so forth and if you
if you break those rules you can be
sanctioned not just professionally but
by the government for for improperly
sharing Secrets pertaining to National
Security so the logic of that is we're
suggesting apply that to wealth managers
and even as we're writing this paper for
pnis Nexus they were governments of the
UK and the European Union and the U.S
were starting to do this with wealth
managers say
um of course you can continue to
practice your profession but you cannot
serve clients who whom we have
sanctioned so do your jobs knock
yourselves out but you can't serve
sanctioned Russian oligarchs and if you
do you will be subject to civil and or
criminal penalties and did that work
I think it's too early to say
um it's only it only just started even
being suggested last June 2022
um right now in fact it's kind of
exciting time to be talking about this
because the Swiss for example they are
actually Prosecuting some Swiss wealth
managers who were serving Russian
oligarchs wow so they're they're
implementing this Theory and like taking
these guys to court right now the
Department of Justice here in the United
States is doing the same thing to wealth
managers that the prosecuting wealth
managers who served sanctioned Russian
oligarchs so this is um very much a a
situation that is unfolding as we speak
it makes me think very much of something
that I've often thought about and is
probably just too hand wavy to be
anything very definite but the very idea
that a wealthy person even like a little
wealthy person like an average middle
class person in the modern world they're
not carrying around gold bullion in an
app stack right they're not they're not
actually in possession of their wealth
the idea of wealth is very much based on
a network of trust that when I log on to
Bank of America's website I can move
zeros and ones around and suddenly a
package appears at my door and uh I
imagine at the level of super duper
wealthy people that you know that
network is is wider and the trust is
even more important
one of the things I would really like to
learn more about
um in the domain of network science and
complex systems is how to conceptualize
and measure trust as as a mechanism
because I'd like to take research
findings from the domain of of Mafia
studies which which are very uh
informative on the Dynamics we're seeing
but they're qualitative I need to be
able to translate those into terms that
can make sense within a complex systems
analysis because you're you're
absolutely right the whole concept of
fiat currency you know the those little
bills that say In God We Trust aren't
about trust trust in the full faith and
credit of the US government or whichever
government is issuing the currency and
then that that's just accentuated the
more you go up the wealth ladder you
need to be able to trust the people who
who know where all the body
who know about the true extent of your
fortune how you got it what the threats
to it really are it's very very
sensitive information so how how
oligarchs establish these trusting
relationships I understand a little bit
about that from my qualitative research
but I haven't developed yet an
understanding of how to conceptualize
and test that as a mechanism but I think
it's very important in addition to um
what's the other mechanism you were
speaking of a preferential attachment
right so I think you know underlying the
preferential attachment is this Dynamic
of trust it makes me think I mean
there's also a political version of this
right if you're a dictator what does it
mean to say that you have power over a
huge number of people ultimately it
means that a small number of people will
listen to your orders and carry them out
and then the large number of people will
listen to their orders and it it strikes
me more that it works at all than the
fact I'm not surprised that it fails
sometimes I'm surprised that so often
people will go along with it
there's a historian named Ruth bengia at
nyu's who wrote a wonderful book called
strongman and it's it's all about the
sort of the psychodynamic of what you're
talking about and
um also relevant to to Mafia studies in
that the way become a strong man is that
you project an image almost like The
Wizard of Oz of of invincibility and you
make sure that no one can look behind
the curtain to the extent that autocrats
or would-be autocrats could be
successful in surrounding themselves
with yes men and with with people who
are willing to commit violence
to to enforce this illusion of
invincibility they'll stay in power and
and Putin has done an incredible job of
that over the last 20 plus years but one
of the objects the ultimate objects of
using sanctions on wealth managers as a
a non-military strategy to counter the
Russian invasion of Ukraine is to begin
to make some of Putin's closest allies
feel some pain not not because we think
they can advise him or change his mind
about anything that's not how they
relate to Putin he tamed the oligarchs
in the early 2000s and they don't tell
them what to do but if they stop
publicly supporting him or if they are
willing to countenance other people
um being disobedient to Putin that
weakens the strong man image and
emboldens others to try to depose him
and this this work to bring down
pinochet's regime in Chile and it worked
to bring down the apartheid regime in
South Africa peeling away the elites
well so you've said this already I don't
want to oversimplify it but uh this
analysis suggests a way for policy
makers thinking about who to sanction
right so include wealth managers as well
as the actual oligarchs and also Target
the hubs Target the ones who are are
most widely connected is this a broader
Paradigm for social science uh research
it makes me think a little bit I did a
podcast a few months ago with Andrew
Papa Christos who is a sociologist who
studies you know Street violence on the
streets of Chicago so a very different
scale but yeah the same network studies
give you like pointers to uh say like
look this person is very likely to not
not necessarily do something bad but be
the target of something bad you don't
know but you know thinking of it in that
way can help us Target our resources for
things that we think are bad and want to
prevent at I think you're absolutely
right and it's interesting that you
bring up the analogy of um
Street crime in Chicago because one of
the things we talk about in this pnas
Nexus article is that the earliest
theorizing in sociology about secrecy
and that's ultimately what the offshore
system is about is secrecy without
secrecy it doesn't work at all
um Georges symbol the German sociologist
who who wrote this sort of foundational
text on on how secrecy Works in human
societies he explicitly made this
connection between
um groups of the nobility who had the
secrets that protected their wealth and
power and and groups of Assassins and
criminals who also use secrecy to
protect themselves from the law from
accountability so an obvious extension
of what we're doing here is to
investigate say terrorists or other
criminal networks because especially the
international ones they work as far as
we know or as far as I've seen on this
Hub and spoke kind of system
so they're robust to certain kinds of
attacks but they're very fragile if you
can find the hubs the trick of it all is
figuring out what are the hubs that is
some of that's the information that's
often guarded with the greatest amount
of secrecy because the people who
organize these networks know that if
anyone knows what the real Hub of the
system is they're in big trouble is
there a flip side if I I don't want to
think about necessarily the offshore
Financial network but is there are there
lessons for people who want to build
robust networks rather than people who
want to attack semi-robus Network yeah I
guess
um one don't put all your eggs in one
basket yeah try to avoid having hubs or
if if you can't avoid having hubs find a
find decoys or other ways to keep the
the nature or location of those hubs
invisible to to inquiring others okay
maybe good maybe a good like last
question years because we've pretty
explicitly touched on not only sociology
but Network science complex systems
occasional analogies with physics and
things like that uh how do we make that
kind of cross-disciplinary interaction
more real intangible and useful I mean
there's sort of lip service given to
yeah sure interdisciplinarity is great
but then when departments hire people
they hire people in their disciplines
because the hiring is done by
departments right do you have any any
words of wisdom for how to make this how
to lower the barriers to this how to
make it natural and and commonplace
rather than the exception
yeah I thought about this a lot the
other thing in addition to hiring is
funding you know yes I do know a lot of
funding agencies talk a good game about
we like to fund high risk
interdisciplinary research but when it
comes right down to it unless the
research is mostly done they're not
going to touch it with a 10-foot pole
because it's too risky and they don't
they don't understand it or you know
just getting reviewers who are
knowledgeable enough about what you're
doing to to evaluate the
cross-disciplinary work it's like it's a
huge uphill battle so
I think it's I think this has to come
this has to be led from the top one of
the things I promised myself this when I
became a tenured full Professor instead
of sitting back and resting on my
Laurels I would use my position to take
bigger risks than I'd ever taken before
so that's one thing and I there are lots
of other similarly positioned Scholars
who can use their their position at the
top of the hierarchy to do things that
would have maybe jeopardized their
careers at an earlier stage
um the second thing is to try to in
addition to taking those risks to
specifically try to build
um institutions and training that will
help bring in younger people post-docs
Junior faculty even undergrad and grad
students to kind of normalize this kind
of work
that's part of The Next Step that that
Herbert and Dan and Fang and I are are
going for here to start building some
kind of institutional infrastructure to
support this Dartmouth itself much like
the Santa Fe Institute provides a a nice
incubator for this kind of work because
like if I worked at maybe Ohio State or
Michigan or some giant University I
think it would be harder for me to like
walk across the street and talk to
someone I didn't know in a completely
different field of inquiry like they'd
have too many people competing for their
time yeah but Dartmouth is really small
and for some people that's a huge
drawback but the silver lining in it for
me at least is that I can go talk to the
chair and math department and like say
yes hi I'm a random sociologist and I
have this idea and would you give me the
time of day and he's got enough
experience of of like mingling with
people from different disciplines
because it's a small place and it's
unavoidable you can't Silo yourself kind
of the way you know people end up around
the lunch table at SFI talking to folks
who are in completely different fields
of work great stuff comes from that so
you know not everyone is lucky enough to
work in a a small institutional
environment where they can just walk
across the street or you know walk
across campus and and get someone in a
completely different field to talk to
them but I think those of us who can do
that should should leverage those
opportunities and build places research
centers or gather funding using the fact
that we are tenured full professors
using our reputations and our networks
to to gain the funding to bring in other
people you know so not just to sponsor
our own research but to become sort of
like many funding agencies for other
people so that we can take a chance on
on their wild ideas just the way
somebody took a chance on my wild idea
15 years ago well from your lips to
God's ears I hope that this is uh
exactly a great Paradigm we're trying to
do similar things at my own new
institution so Brooke Harrington thanks
so much for being on the mindscape
podcast thank you it's a pleasure
[Music]
la la la la